tell a joke again what's the only thing
worse than giving head to Willie
Nelson what if he says I'm not Willie
Nelson what's that Mr parrot I know he's
not funny he's better he's he thinks
he's better on Twitter but that's not
nice to say right in front of his
face just think how he
feels the statue's chance murmur is you
chance it's called chance murmur chance
murmur God that's so beautiful that's
gorgeous this is this is another reason
I hate cynicism and I talk about this a
lot even just on Etsy there's so many
small not huge companies like individual
Artisans who are creating great stuff um
and just making it happen and it's
really sad for me where people can't see
that or if they're like well how could I
be excited about a sculpture when blah
blah blah the Middle East and it's just
like you can always look for an excuse
not to look for Joy or you could look
for an excuse to look for Joy yeah that
se's incredible I feel the same way
but only fans I I can't even get that
out of my mouth before laughing at my
own failed joke that's what she said I
did
oh H all right that might be one of the
first that's what she said from a
Michael malice yeah I'm going to count
that I don't know what I'm going to do
with mine cuz I got my own mine's three
F feet tall just like me your box was
much bigger yeah and it was giving me an
inferiority complex I think I'm going to
invade
Russia that's a Napoleon
reference for those in the audience um I
don't know if I'm going to I think I'm
put in my bedroom so it's the first
thing I see when I wake up put it in the
bedroom
yeah